quel clown blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir dont
je maison merci d'être avec nous ce
résultat des législatives en arménie
pour voir ce qu'il est surprenant
ça démontre en tout cas que les
instituts de sondage arméniens ne sont
pas très fiable puisqu'il avait donné
les deux principaux candidats au coude à
coude avec eux mêmes une préférence pour
pour celui qui semble-t-il a été battu
la deuxième conclusion c'est que dans le
fond et c'est confirmé lorsqu'on
interroge des arméniens dans le fond
peut-être que l'offre politique
n'étaient pas optimum pour les arméniens
et qu'ils ont fait un choix du moindre
mal et il préfère finalement avoir peu
de signal qui s'occupera du
développement économique et social
plutôt que d'avoir coach ian qui
probablement prendre à une attitude
revancharde par rapport à la défaite
militaire
en tout cas les organisations
internationales qui avait envoyé
beaucoup d'observateurs l'organisation
pour la sécurité et la coopération en
europe dont l'arménie comme la russie
comme tous les pays européens font
partie eux aussi le conseil de l'europe
l'assemblée parlementaire du conseil de
l'europe avait envoyé des observateurs
et ses 300 observateurs ont conclu que
dans l'ensemble l'élection s'était
déroulée dans des conditions normales
dans des conditions convenables ici ou
là il ya peut-être en effet quelques
incidents qu'il faut certainement
expertise et analyser mais globalement
le résultat semble acquis d'autant plus
que la défiance il est énorme puisqu'il
ya 22 points qui séparent le score de
monsieur patxi diane qui a 22 points de
plus que son concurrent
donc il y aura sans doute encore des
contestations mais je crois que les
arméniens se sont prononcés alors
quelles tâches attendent le gouvernement
pashinian la première c'est certainement
de de tout faire pour réconcilier les
arméniens entre eux
puisque comme on vient de le dire et
comme votre micro trottoir la montre et
les arméniens sont divisés et la période
récente a polarisé encore plus les
opinions politiques
la deuxième tâche c'est d'aider les
familles qui ont eu un deuil dans la
guerre il ya quand même eu 6500 morts et
bien à faire ce deuil et à accepter
cette situation
et puis pour le reste la tâche sera pour
l'essentiel une tâche économique et
social relancer l'économie parce que
l'arménie a subi un double choc c'est un
des seuls pays à avoir subi un tel
double choc
le choc de la guerre avec l'azerbaïdjan
et le choc de la pandémie due que 8,19
et par conséquent quotidienne a commencé
à mettre en place un plan de relance à
hauteur à une hauteur de d'un budget qui
correspond à peu près à deux et demi
pour cent du pnb de l'arménie les
grandes organisations financières
internationales ont entrepris d'aider
l'arménie puisque fin 2020 le fonds
monétaire international a décidé d'aider
la vni elle al'air l'arménie à hauteur
de 400 millions de dollars
et puis par ailleurs puisqu'il ya un
accord avec l'union européenne
l'union européenne a donné une aide
d'urgence de 100 millions d'euros plus
une aide budgétaire de 40 millions
d'euros
par ailleurs l'arménie fait partie de
l'union économique eurasiatique
elle en fait partie c'est évidemment une
d'abord une zone de libre échange qui va
vers une union douanière mais qui
comporte aussi des mécanismes de
solidarité et l'arménie en bénéficiera
dans la période qui vient elle en a
besoin parce que ses exportations qui
sont essentiellement les exportations
agricoles et des exportations de
minerais donc pas rien que des produits
primaires se sont effondrés parce que la
demande s'est effondrée elle s'était
faudrait à l'intérieur de l'union
eurasiatique mais aussi ailleurs en
europe et par conséquent l'économie
l'économie est en mauvais état l'effort
de guerre a été évidemment trop
important pour ce petit pays qui n'a pas
de ressources pétrolières
il n'a pas de ressources particulières
donc c'est ça le défi de monsieur pat
chilien lé du gouvernement il va
maintenant s'installer
sept mois après la signature du
cessez-le-feu club en raison on peut se
demander quelles sont les relations
désormais avec l'azerbaïdjan
alors elles sont difficiles puisque
comme on le sait ce conflit de six
semaines s'est terminée par un cessez le
feu signé à moscou le 10 novembre
dernier et les clauses de ce cessez le
feu comporte notamment des échanges de
population c'est à dire que puisque la
verbal gens à regagner du territoire des
territoires qui avait été conquis par
l'arménie en 94 et bien les populations
arméniennes qui s'étaient installés ont
dû partir et les avery ils sont revenus
mais on constate que ces derniers jours
ces derniers temps un regain de tensions
aux frontières entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie regarde tension qui fait que
les troupes de maintien de la paix de la
russie qui sont prévus dans cet accord
de cessez-le-feu environ deux mille
hommes et bien ont aussi un rôle de
médiation pour convaincre les militaires
azerbaïdjanais de ne pas prendre
l'aventage sur le terrain là où ce
n'était pas prévu d'ailleurs depuis le
début de ce conflit la russie a trait
marque très très nettement marqué les
bandes rouges c'est à dire qu'il n'était
pas question pour réservé à des gens
pénètrent sur le territoire de la mairie
la guerre portés certainement sur le
nagorny karabakh et sur les zones
tampons qui avait été conquise par
l'arménie en 1994 mais l'arménie faisant
partie de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective
c'est une sorte d'alliance militaire
avec la russie il était évidemment pas
question que l'azerbaïdjan s'attaque au
territoire même de l'arménie alors pour
le reste il y à un couloir qui permet de
maintenir un contact entre le nagorny
karabakh ou ce qui en reste et l'arménie
et la liberté de circulation est
garantie par les troupes de maintien de
la paix russes et puis il ya aussi dans
cet accord la mention du fait que au sud
de l'arménie doit se construire une
route et une voie de chemin de fer qui
assureront la liberté de circulation des
personnes et des marchandises entre 2,4
et vannes qui est un territoire autonome
de l'azerbaïdjan et l'azerbaïdjan
lui-même en traversant par conséquent le
sud de l'arménie alors évidemment et une
divergence d'interprétation de cette
clause puisque l'azerbaïdjan voudrait
construire une route qu'il contrôlerait
voudrait construire un nouveau chemin de
fer qu'il contrôlerait alors que
l'accord la lettre de l'accord prévoit
une liberté de circulation garantie par
les gardes frontières du fsb russe qui
fait partie des troupes de maintien de
la paix donc là dessus les discussions
vont certainement continuer c'est très
important pour le verbe ajjan
parce que cette liaison c'te physique
permettrait de relier la caspienne à la
mer noire permettraient de relier
l'azerbaïdjan à son allié turc
et les turcs probablement souhaite aussi
joué un rôle dans la construction ses
infrastructures ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement l'intérêt de la russie
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales